you know they're in the top 20 than both
offense and defense and that's a
prerequisite to being a national
championship team Brandon Clark gets
good position Fortuna
Perkins will bring the ball up the floor
good pants
Clark crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
Devante Pandu coughs it up and here they
come in transition
kiss Burt will step into a crazed
[Applause]
Devante Pandu coughs it up and here they
come in transition
kiss Burt will step into a play
especially for a guy who's a great
offensive rebounder and here's the brake
work show Todd hits so late I'm Tilly
with the shot clock down to five Perkins
inside Clark to war
has six points bench with two fouls a
turnover two-on-one Perkins and Crandall
they leave it for club another Jam for
Brandon flurry
the middle of that zone and get the ball
a lot Birkins no luck to Clark and he
connects again cork is now 5 out of 6
for 10 points
he's 2.7 all content when the top teams
in the country this is per gate
Clark pokes it away and that could be in
a playground one on Cutler Tilly feeds
Clark and exploit this but the tip is
there is it going to easy with the show
The Trews got to make it halftime is
maybe drive a little Gonzaga
under mark few when leading by at least
15 points at the half in 178 in own
pitch that zone which I can't blame
let's see if they get it inside Clark
left alone he can't do that with Brandon
Clark as this league gets back up a
little bit he'll be in quick now it's
Gillespie trying to guard Clark Clark
turn around
Wow
22 is for Clark it wants to draw some
contact there on Clark pieces guys first
you got to stay stationary take the
contacts
[Applause]
quality of the shots for Baylor
Clark with a Glock
one of those six on the year you really
careful Clark push by them here they are
matched up down low vital barely booth
yeah be back deft I've got by the camp
guard are Lisa thank you very much his
Clark a layer of his but guess what it
gets it back and soft Ileana tuned
got to get around hot your [ __ ]
triumph front both follow the front
Clark
Brandon floor now with 30 and all
pensively tonight they have shown again
they are a force to be reckoned with
Clark's part to this man 32 for glory
[Applause]
Louisville shot clock at five doorbell
hands off Clark called it X scores great
hands for Brandon Clark who played this
out some limit this perp wide open
[Applause]